An important part of your image
making, mostly small devices,
is what you use for backgrounds,
or how to view backgrounds.
You know, you can make some very
interesting images even more
interesting if you
subtlety suggest
a certain kind of background
that works, that's relevant.
Your selection can
really change your image.
Sometimes you have
to be kind of careful
'cause the background can
overtake what you want to say
and we'll see that in a moment.
So take for example
this image that I made
of an assemblage of pieces.
And I took it on a surface
against a white wall, which
is what a lot of you do
and, the issue for me
is that even though you don't
think that the view sees it,
the viewer does see the
horizon, where the two pieces
of material meet.
You might say, 'Well,
what what's the big deal'?
Well, you should
start really getting
into the habit of trying to edit
out anything that is ambiguous
or that is not giving the viewer
a very clear view of what it
is that you want them to see.
So it's much better to just
keep a piece of paper handy,
and just simply fold
it up towards the back
and you'll get yourself
a very nice background
without seeing that
distracting horizontal line.
I really do suggest
you you start
doing these kinds of things.
It's easy with
such small devices.
Here's a device that was taken
just in the lab, a quick image.
And once again, the researcher
knows what it is to look
for, but you cannot expect the
first-time viewer to see what
you want them to see.
And so they do see all
the mess behind it.
So, just take that
piece of paper
that we used before, and
just put the device on it.
Lean it against
the same background
that you had before, but this
time with the paper going up;
hiding that material
in the back,
you can see much a
much clearing device.
Sometimes echoing what
you're looking at,
it could be very helpful.
I was asked to take some images
of some copper sulfate crystals
and so I found a
piece of copper -
two pieces of copper
actually - and just
suggested the presence of
copper in this material.
And here, with
these plastic shapes
that were fabricated
in a lab, I just
thought it would be fun
to put it against a grid.
Not a very [laughs]
clean grid ' by the way,
this was taken quite
a long time ago.
But what it did show was sort of
helping to define these shapes
and how those lines were changed
when these plastic pieces were
put over it.
Here's an image I
took for a book trying
to talk about a drop of water,
which is very complicated.
And what I did was -- remember
we're using a 105 lens focusing
on the drop so, as you
probably know by now,
you can get a very narrow
depth of field when you use 105
lenses, which is what
we wanted in this case,
because the
background is blurred.
The next image shows
you the background.
I mean, it's something I bought
quite a while ago knowing
someday I would use
it for a background
because I like the look of it.
And I also knew that
with a 105 lens,
it would become a whole
different thing, as you see.
Take a real hard
look at that drop
and you'll see that
the drop itself
became a lens that has
focused the background.
So, it's a little playful thing
that I forgot what happened,
but it did.
But here's a background
that is totally out of focus
that you want to
be out of focus.
Otherwise it would just
be too much of an image.
On this one image of a
bacillus in a petri dish,
I just decided to
layer the petri dish
on a particular
plastic blue, and then
I put the blue over orange
and I was having kind of fun.
On this one, we're showing
sketches of the CAD
that was used to
make these devices.
And it's just a sketchy-like
idea, which I like very much.
I still like the idea of showing
some sort of a human hand
to the fabrication of
very high technology.
I think that we should use
more of these kinds of ideas
as my point of view.
And here's another.
It's a wafer made
into electronic device
with one background.
And I took the same wafer and
put it on another background,
and then again on
another background .
And changing the
angle a little bit
so you actually see a very
different color pallet.
And that's what
I'm talking about.
It's all related.
You make one change in
one spot and then it's
going to change your composition
or your point of view,
it's just ongoing,
the permutations.
For this image, we wanted
to show the ability
to make these
crystals, and I decided
to use some weighing
paper against a desk
and it just happens that
the light is coming in
from the window and I actually
used it compositionally
and as part of the background.
And here, we're seeing material
that results into a powder.
And again, I'm
using weighing paper
and make it a sort of
interesting overlay of shapes
because it's a pretty
boring picture otherwise.
I think it's a little
more successful.
And these are things that
are not easy to photograph,
as I'm sure you know.
And on this, I used a
reflective quality of glass.
Ah, it might not
be as successful
as I thought because
maybe you can't quite
tell where the glass begins
in the real slide with these.
These are highly
hydrophobic slides,
that's why you're seeing
the water bubble as it does.
I don't know, it's
something to think about.
And here I used, I
kind of was echoing
the shape of this material, how
it coils into these nice scoops
and I decided to
use a small table
to echo the shape of the
naturally occurring curves.
Here's an example where I put
the device on stick-ems, just
a blue post-it
onto which on that
I put a post-it on
a black surface.
I think this works.
I think the next one where
I used a crazy background.
Look I got a card that
I though was very fun.
It's fun to look at the card,
but not with the device on it.
It's just way way
over the top and too
much with the background,
just really gets in the way.
I needed to take a photograph
of this very small robot, flying
robot, which measures
about one centimeter long.
And, used the box that the (the
plastic box that it arrived in)
as part of the
composition which I think
fills the background
in an interesting way.
In this image, this
was a very quick image
that I just made
just to see how,
what kind of depth
of field I was
gonna get with these devices.
And it turns out that I sort
of like the haphazardness
of this image.
The background just
was accidental.
For me, it works.
Maybe not for you,
but for me it does.
Backgrounds should be
part of your vocabulary.
There is no question
in my mind about that.